hey david on balance do you think that
the protests
help or hurt donald trump uh i think
that they heard him
i i believe that early the idea that
trump had was that they would help
i just think he miscalculated there is
no question
that when you see protests some small
portion of which
end up having some violent elements and
arrests taking place
arson looting etc certainly trump's base
is activated they are motivated they
become more enthusiastic about
voting for donald trump i don't deny
that the problem is i think that the
protests are really hurting trump with
everybody who's not already committed to
him and
if you only are pleasing the people
already voting for you
you can't make up a three five seven or
nine point popular vote deficit which is
what different polls
claim donald trump is currently
experiencing
most people aren't falling for if you
see
a violent confrontation in portland
that's what you will have under joe
biden's america
most people aren't falling for that most
people are accurately recognizing wait a
second
biden's america trump's president right
now
this is happening in trump's america
right now and it reminds me a little bit
of the
the situation when donald trump was
asked about
early in coronavirus earlier in corona
virus do you take responsibility for
this or that
and trump said i take no responsibility
at all apply
that logic to the protests
and to the elements of the protests that
have been violent which again is very
very small
and trump actually spotlights those
incidents
thinking it will hurt joe biden and he
says it's biden's fault that this is
happening
it's radical marxist fault that this is
happening and it will be even worse if
they win
it's backfiring because it doesn't pass
the sniff test and what this ultimately
gets back to
is that donald trump was a much stronger
candidate running as an insurgent
who had not had a career in politics and
who could
sort of credibly criticize whoever is
running and whoever is in power
trump's been president now for four
years and yet he's still trying
to run like an insurgent trump is still
saying you've got to re-elect me
so i can do the wall and do health care
and do more taxes and all of this other
stuff he's been president for four years
and it's a gambit
that i believe has failed him he may
still win for other reasons but i think
continuing to run as an outsider even
though he's been president now for four
years
i think it's a mistake and if you look
at the polling data you see it
um when the unrest happened in wisconsin
there were people saying this is going
to hurt joe biden and it's going to hurt
democrats
you had enlightened centrist grifters
right saying trump just won
the senate is going to stay republican
because of what's going on in wisconsin
a lot of pundits jumped all over that
not pundents as some say pundits come on
we know the word p-u-n-d-i-t
and in fact joe biden is polling
slightly better today in wisconsin than
he was
uh when jacob blake got shot it's
marginal it's a small
it's a small delta but things have not
gotten worse for joe biden in wisconsin
since that happened and i think that
what's happening or two different things
one
most people aren't buying that what
we're seeing has anything to do with joe
biden it's happening under donald trump
and trump's actions have actually
worsened it when trump
sent federal agents like jack-booted
thugs
to areas with unrest to carry out you
know authoritarian
soviet-style tactics throwing people
into vans and all of this stuff
he could have instead used the bully
pulpit
to say we are demanding federal
investigations of the police officers
and departments involved
this is not what the next four years are
going to look like
in america he could have listened to
people on systemic race
right he could have done it differently
and i think he'd be cruising to
re-election if he had done that
and paid more attention to the virus for
sure
but instead he didn't do that and uh
it it has made it it has fomented
the feeling that things are unstable and
instability tends not to be good for the
incumbent so that's my bottom line i
think that donald trump's
base is certainly enthusiastically going
to vote for trump
because of the protest but they were
going to vote for trump anyway maybe
they're just doing it slightly more
enthusiastically
i think with everybody else the protests
have been very very bad for donald trump